et maxim lykov un des fondateurs du
mouvement des gilet jaune et vous êtes
de plus en plus virulents maxime moi je
vous le dit maxime de suite et je
démarre l'émission là dessus on s'est
rencontré il ya quelques semaines sur ce
plateau une semaine plusieurs semaines
moi j'ai toujours été c'est vrai plutôt
gilet jaune
j'ai toujours accepté que vous veniez
sur mes plateaux et je préfère vous dire
les choses parce que voilà moi je les
dis toujours j'ai été j'ai été déçu par
certaines déclarations vous avez fait
par exemple
après on va pas revenir là dessus mais
sur des déclarations par exemple
complotistes que vous avez pu faire sur
des déclarations aussi un peu trop
violente que vous avez pu faire sur
votre facebook live moi j'ai pas reconnu
j'vous dit maxime j'ai pas reconnu le
garçon qui était avec moi il ya
plusieurs semaines et qui me disait même
dans les loges
voilà moi cyril j'en peux plus je craque
moi je n'arrive pas à m'en sortir et il
ya plein de gens que je vois autour de
moi qui arrive pas à s'en sortir et si
je suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour dire
qu'il ya plein de gens en détresse et
qu'on a envie de faire avancer les
choses pour eux et j'ai vu une dérive de
votre part ça m'a déçu parce que je vois
là on avait bien discuté ensemble et
j'ai été déçu
voilà je vous le dis je trouve qu'il ya
eu pas mal de dérives dans tout ce que
vous avez dit sur les bras je sais que
vous voulez pas qu'on en parle mais sur
les attentats de strasbourg ce que vous
avez pu déclarer c'est inadmissible pour
les familles des victimes déjà et c'est
vrai quoi là c'est pas le garçon que
j'avais vu la quitte avec moi je me
rappelle très bien vous étiez assis là
la première fois qu'on s'est vus et
c'est pas le garçon que j'avais vu là
qu'ils étaient plus dans des
revendications sociales dans des
revendications plutôt qui touchait tout
le monde l'a et est ce que vous
regrettez un moment ce que vous avez pu
dire ou pas non mais franchement
alors ce que j'ai dit sur les attentats
c'est quoi qui dérange en fait c'est le
fait que je dise que il n'y a pas eu de
mettez en doute le caractère terroriste
de l'attentât c'est inadmissible
caractère terroriste c'est un terroriste
qui a fait un attentat ça va j'ai dit et
je le dis dans la vidéo c'est que le
lien avec al qaïda
donc l' entreprise terroriste il n'est
pas établi qu'est ce que ça change
quelque chose au fait qu'il ya un cinglé
qui a tué cinq personnes
non que les services de sécurité et de
l'état n'ont pas empêcher quelqu'un de
maxime vous pouvez pas dire que le
gouvernement est derrière ces attentats
j'ai jamais dit que le gouvernement
était derrière ces attentats jeudi jeudi
il avait dit jeudi qu'une personne qui
est connu des services de police qui est
fiché est ce qui a plus de vingt
condamnations qui peut se balader
librement
c'est normal donc on interpelle en amont
bien sûr notre plein en avant claque
avant qu'il y ait quelque chose de komi
bacchantes quand ils canton c'est
illégal donc quand on sait qu'il est
radicalisée dans la pensée rp les
abondances car on sait qu'il est
radicalisée dans la pensée des patrons
sait qu'il a plus de vingt condamnations
quand on sait qu'il est suivi par la
dgsi la dgse quand on sait qu'il appelle
sa famille en disant qu'il va se
suicider quand on sait qu il dit qu'il
va commettre des actes peut-être
terroristes on n'interpelle pas avant on
attend qu'ils donc on interpelle avant
il y avait quelqu'un vous avez créé un
risque comme ça oui on interpelle avons
bien su alors on va pas on va avant
avant kg est un crime ou un délit que
ceux commis en faisant sien que les gens
si vous avez des attentats à toi
n'attendra pas rentrer tout de suite
dans le débat ça honteux dans le débat
c'est vous plaît s'il vous plaît
monsieur m m je voulais juste me dire ça
l'aifa maxime et les différentes soupes
et les différents posts sur facebook
maxime on vous a on a vu plusieurs posts
sur facebook moi qui m'ont un peu choqué